après j'ai contacté son mari Bernard
Dormal bravo je vais vous lire le SMS
qui m'a envoyé en tout cas et merci à
lui d'avoir tout à l'heure bonjour
chérie ne vous inquiétez pas j'ai
retrouvé Brigitte qui avait fuit aux
îles Caïmans et Pierre Palmade mais
après ça sensation l'ignore encore
d'accord bon donc je vous embrasse tous
les deux bien sûr voilà donc beaucoup
d'humour en tout cas merci à lui d'avoir
répondu c'est vrai que parce que je sais
que Fabien les gens on a été inquiets
voilà moi je sais que même même ma mère
m'en a parlé ce weekend elle m'a dit
Brigitte Bardot il paraît qu'elle est
parce que
pour des millions de personnes en France
elle a été la plus grande star mondiale
comme le disait Bigot évidemment
elle a rassemblé des millions et des
millions de personnes dans 171 pays
c'est une immense icône en tout cas donc
le fait qu'on sache qu'elle est déjà
quand même âgée pratiquement de 89 ans
dans quelques mois on sait que
évidemment elle souffre d'insuffisance
respiratoire
elle s'est échappée de l'hôpital pour ne
pas y rester parce déjà une forte tête
elle a une vraie personnalité en tout
cas et voilà donc on est tous un peu
inquiet et puis elle a jamais elle s'est
exprimée une fois elle voulait elle
n'aime pas les piqûres elle n'aime pas
les anesthésies donc elle a jamais voulu
se faire opérer ni rien non parce que sa
mère est morte sous anesthésie
absolument entre toute la garder
également absolument c'est meilleur
elle a des problèmes
avec deux béquilles et se déplacent
évidemment difficilement pour aller voir
ses bêtes mais elle refuse absolument de
se faire opérer et c'est une femme très
importante pour notre société vraiment
elle a été essentielle ce que je vois
tout le monde qui est inquiet
aujourd'hui c'est donc c'est voilà parce
que bon moi
je savais comment on voit cette
inquiétude c'est quand la presse
commence à préparer tous ces dossiers et
donc là ou quand vous appelez pour enfin
pas moi spécialement mais on sait que
déjà tous les hors-séries sont prêts
ceci cela et ça mais dès qu'on arrive à
70 75 ans de toute manière en France
soyons pas hypocrites encore une fois de
plus Daniel tu vas voir
[Rires]
manque de bois là-dessus tous les grands
producteurs de télé tous les animateurs
enfin les la presse tout ce qui va
intéresser évidemment là on a déjà tout
préparé mais déjà pas cette semaine tout
est prêt déjà depuis on va dire trois
ans vous dites tout est prêt c'est quoi
des photos
c'est à dire quand on vous sort un
hors-série par exemple Paris Match va
faire leur série Le Parisien peut-être
le Figaro bon ben déjà toutes les nécros
sont préparés il y a le numéro de
légende le numéro de gens remarquement
voilà donc en fait alors il y a une
forme d'hypocrisie parce qu'on a pas le
droit de le dire ça alors mais c'est un
métier qui est comme ça Brigitte Bardot
a été hospitalisé en toute discrétion à
Toulon il y a quelques semaines aucune
information n'a été dévoilée concernant
cette hospitalisation avant ce weekend
pourquoi
ça c'est ça pas fuité ce qu'on a peur
des bavardages parce que je pense que
l'entourage il se méfie Brigitte la
première et que voilà ils aiment pas je
crois qu'à un moment donné
c'est Bernard et Bernard
elle aurait été donc vous l'avez dit
elle a une insuffisance respiratoire et
comme vous l'avez dit c'est vrai que les
fous elle la décision de ne pas suivre
la vie des médecins il y aurait prescrit
donc trois semaines de convalescence au
sein de l'établissement hospitalier elle
a décidé de sortir au bout de quatre
jours d'hospitalisation enceinte en
soins intensif donc là elle est où elle
est sortie de l'hôpital elle est à la
Madrague oui bien sûr
j'ai une de mes amis journalistes qui
doit l'avoir ce weekend mais voilà alors
de ce qu'on de ce qui se dit cette
décision n'était sûrement pas la
meilleure ce qui dit elle aurait dû
rester voilà en observation et Gilles
c'est ça elle est très affaiblie en fait
depuis plusieurs semaines c'est ça qui
est absolument et il y a quelques
semaines à Villeneuve-Loubet dans le sud
on a décidé de créer un boulevard
Brigitte Bardot et les élus à ce
moment-là avait dit on espère que l'état
de santé lui permettra de venir mais
rien ne permet de l'assurer oui mais son
état de santé c'est qu'elle a du mal à
se déplacer oui mais elle est faible
aussi parce qu'il y a aussi des
problèmes d'expression Macron dit elle a
du mal à parler elle écrit difficilement
donc il y a une grande fatigue générale
c'est ça qui inquiète en ce moment Cyril
pas beaucoup parler aussi c'est souvent
de prétexte alors elle est née le 28
septembre 1934 elle est balance comme
moi elle a arrêté le 110 mètres puis un
moment ici c'est ça alors elle a déjà eu
des problèmes de santé oui bien sûr 84
un cancer du sein alors qu'elle était
âgé de 49 ans Brigitte Bardot cette
époque etc trouvé en conflit avec les
médecins et son well les journalistes
l'auraient aussi traîné dans la boue en
l'accusant notamment d'être raciste
regardez
j'ai pas élevé Nicolas parce que je vais
vous dire j'étais pas capable d'élever
Nicolas
j'ai besoin que on s'occupe de moi je
suis très remontée contre les politiques
contre les certains journalistes qui
m'ont traîné dans la boue je continue tu
me traite de raciste parce que je suis
contre les abattages rituels par exemple
ça me donne mal au corps j'ai envie de
vomir ce que c'est dégueulasse sans les
étourdir c'est ça
toujours eu des combats Bardot mais bon
on est habitué à ces paroles en même
temps bon on peut défendre sa carrière
son talent et pas forcément elle a été
la première à défendre le bien-être
animal mais c'est vrai aussi donc elle a
été pionnière au cinéma elle a été
pionnière du féminisme et elle a été
aussi pionnière de la défense des
animaux et c'est vrai que ça l'a fait
personnellement intimement souffrir la
souffrance animale c'est c'est une
empathie particulière qu'elle a dès
qu'on touche aux animaux
c'est d'une certaine façon elle explose
elle ne se contrôle plus parce qu'elle
partage leur souffrance alors il y a des
journalistes également qui disent
qu'elle voulait rentrer chez elle par se
reposer parce que voilà elle a pas envie
voilà le reste à l'hôpital elle a peur
de rester à l'hôpital aussi parce que ça
me livre même dans justement le côté
médical parce qu'elle devait faire une
chimio quand elle a eu ce cancer du sein
elle a refusé c'est le fameux conflit
avec la médecine donc elle voilà
exactement elle veut pas se faire opérer
parce qu'elle a peur elle est libre même
dans ce domaine médical donc là elle est
partie avant la fin de comment dire un
sacré
même pour sa santé en fait elle a été la
première femme libre moi cette histoire
qui est formidable quand elle tourne son
film chalako en Espagne en 1968 c'est
une connerie qui vient la voir après le
tournage
dans sa chambre il arrive tout nu avec
des chaussettes au pied elle le met
dehors et le dégage alors que quand je
suis une connerie absolument donc ça
c'est une histoire à ça c'est la
première femme qui s'est levée qui a dit
non et c'est elle était très très
importante dans notre société elle avait
déjà elle avait dit cette chose
merveilleuse quand elle était jeune elle
disait j'avais entendu Vadim donc son
premier mari Roger badine mais avait dit
un jour j'ai entendu Vadim me dire
en France quand un homme a des
maîtresses on dit que c'est un don Juan
quand une femme a des amants on dit que
c'est une [__] ou une [__] et je ne
peux pas accepter ça je ne peux pas
accepter cette idée j'ai décidé que je
me battrai contre toute ma vie c'est
c'est remarquable alors elle parle elle
parle elle n'hésite pas aussi à parler
de sa mort en 2020 l'invindiquer lors
d'un entretien pour point de vue vouloir
simplement une petite croix en bois mon
nom m'a date de naissance ma date ma
date de mort une petite croix en bois
rien d'autre comme je l'ai fait pour mes
chiens mes chats mes chevaux mes moutons
que je rejoindrai je vous rassure je ne
suis pas prête à mourir
mais quand cela arrivera je souhaite un
retour à la terre à l'essentiel il n'y
plus beau il y a des gens qui disent
qu'elle voulait revenir aussi chez eux
parce que sentez fatigué Gilles
le retour chez elle c'est vrai qu'elle a
quitté précipitamment l'hôpital quand
même contre la vie des médecins l'ont
beaucoup de gens sont dit elle voit sa
dernière heure arriver on en est pas là
mais c'est vrai que il y a voilà il y a
une fatigue générale non il vous n'avez
pas l'air d'accord mais il y a une
fatigue générale quand même non mais
c'est tellement son caractère surtout
c'est imprévisible elle est indomptable
c'est ça voilà donc Brigitte on lui dit
vous devez aller à l'hôpital ça
l'emmerde elle a aucune envie d'y aller
et elle n'a qu'une idée c'est de se
tirer de là au plus vite et les hôpitaux
elle connaît parce que elle a connu
c'était elle parlait tout à l'heure de
sa relation avec son fils sa relation
très complexe qui qui a pu choquer
d'ailleurs mais elle a subi un très
grand nombre d'avortement donc elle sait
ce que c'est l'hôpital et c'est ce que
c'est la souffrance physique et morale
alors qui accompagne ça et une des
raisons pour lesquelles elle a cette
relation difficile avec son fils c'est
que quand elle s'est retrouvée enceinte
ce jour-là elle aurait souhaité
avorter à ce moment-là mais justement
comme elle avait une pression de la
presse et que ça s'est su mais elle ne
pouvait plus l'assumer jusque là elle
avait réussi des avortements clandestins
là elle ne pouvait pas le faire aux yeux
du monde et du coup ça c'est cette
pression qui a gâché sa relation de et
sa condition de merde c'est des mots qui
ont choqué dans son autobiographie
d'ailleurs parce que quand elle parle de
Nicolas elle elle raconte ça elle dit je
voulais pas cet enfant et j'aurais voulu
cash elle dit ce qu'elle pense c'est
France dimanche aucun filtre Gilles
c'est France Dimanche qui a sorti voilà
France Dimanche qui est parfois un
journal contesté mais qui a des infos
qui travaillent sur le sujet qui a des
infos et donc qui a sorti et donc la
France était hospitalisée à Toulon ce
qui était resté confidentiel et que les
médecins auraient préféré qu'elle reste
trois semaines qu'elle a précipitamment
regagné ses domiciles ce qui a alimenté
quand même les spéculations sur la
réalité de son état de santé voilà on
sait pas tout à fait l'AFP
en tout cas ils ont sorti le truc moi
alors Brigitte Brigitte Bardot en vogue
au globalement aux humains regardez
Brigitte quand vous vous retrouvez
devant Dieu qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
qu'il vous dise ah j'ai pas perdu mon
temps et qu'est-ce que vous direz vous
d'accord je suis bien contente d'être
près de lui parce que on peut marre de
connard voilà c'est pour ça que vous
vous êtes un peu retiré du monde un peu
comme ça on a l'impression ouais j'ai
rien à dire à des gens qui sont sans
intérêt et j'ai pas envie d'écouter leur
bêtises genre connerie donc je préfère
être seul
faut dire elle a tellement souffert du
regard sur elle sur son corps de ne pas
avoir de vie privée de vie possible etc
elle a été sous le regard permanent des
appareils photos et des caméras de 1956
à à peu près 1973 c'est-à-dire toute sa
jeunesse et ça l'a rendu assez
misanthrope parce que
c'est sa vie qui était qui était volée
et
ça ne l'a pas permis de garder de
relations non plus amoureuse parce que
voilà à chaque fois la pression qui
était mise sur elle sur son couple sur
son compagnon faisait que ça ne pouvait
pas
durer donc ça lui a donné en rejet comme
ça de ces semblables et puis après il y
a le traitement des animaux aussi qui
lui a beaucoup des plumes elle a aussi
des déclarations qui ont fait polémiques
des déclarations sur l'islam en le
métissage des prises de position qui lui
vaudront plusieurs condamnations pénales
pour un Sidation à la haine raciale elle
a été condamnée pour un jour Assia à
plusieurs reprises c'est ça plusieurs
comptes condamnations pour un citation à
la haine envers la communauté musulmane
5 à 11 ans par exemple en deux ans 2006
à la vadresser une lettre à Nicolas
Sarkozy dans laquelle elle déclarait au
sujet de la communauté musulmane il y en
a marre d'être mené par le bout du nez
par toute cette population qui nous
détruit détruit notre pays en imposant
ses actes alors c'est pas bien et
d'ailleurs la justice là c'est pas bien
c'est pas le plus bel aspect de sa
personnalité loin de là
le départ de ce qu'il faut comprendre si
on veut s'intéresser un peu au-delà de
mais voilà de me récompense d'une
réaction
épidermique c'est que elles sont
problème c'est l'Aïd c'est elle ne veut
pas qu'on dégorge les moutons vivants
donc elle estime d'un seul coup que donc
c'était pas ça que
après le problème de Brigitte Bardot
alors que c'est une femme extrêmement
intelligente et qui écrit de manière
absolument remarquable un français
impeccable c'est que elle pratique
l'amalgame c'est-à-dire que elle va dire
les musulmans ceci les ceci les ceux-là
les homosexuels pendant un moment elle a
parlé des homosexuels homosexuels ont
toujours eu un goût et un talent plus
subtil une classe une envergure une
intelligence jusqu'à ce que tout ça
dégénère en lopède de base étage travelo
de tout poil phénomène de foie
tristement stimulé par dans cette
décadence par la levée d'interdit qui
endiguer les débordements extrêmes voilà
alors le problème c'est l'amalgame
d'ailleurs la plupart de son entourage
sont des homosexuels donc c'est pas la
question c'est que Brigitte elle n'est
elle est incapable de racisme de haine
c'est quelqu'un de très généreux de très
ouvert et incapable de détester
quelqu'un pour sa couleur de peau pour
sa religion pour son orientation
sexuelle etc pratique l'amalgame c'est à
dire c'est les musulmans les homosexuels
mais jamais une personne qui va être
devant elle alors c'est pas bien en
termes d'éducation ce qu'elle fait elle
a pas une bonne communication et ça lui
donne notamment auprès de la jeune
génération ou de votre génération Cyril
mais vous êtes jeune
c'est oui oui
ça lui donne une mauvaise image et c'est
dommage parce que c'est pas la réalité
d'accord de son cœur et c'est pas la
réalité de sa vie de dire mais elle a
besoin d'en dire comme je te dis Yves
parce que moi voilà j'ai pas suivi mais
c'est vrai que dans ma tête quand on
Brigitte Bardot c'est vrai voilà tu vois
je me dis ça c'est c'est entacher moi ma
mère était fan de Brigitte Bardot absolu
c'est rigolade me dit ouais c'est vrai
qu'elle a eu deux trois déclarations
voilà même voilà mais toi pour toi c'est
c'est quoi elle a dit des choses qui est
qu'elle est pensé pas voilà c'est quoi
alors c'est pas qu'elle le pense pas
c'est qu'elle amalgame
c'est d'abord elle a des colères elle
est sans filtre déjà elle a des colères
dès qu'elle ressent quelque chose elle
le dit et puis comme évidemment dès
qu'elle dit quelque chose ben tout le
monde est là pour le recueillir pour le
relancer le commenter etc ça fait ça
fait boule de neige c'est quelqu'un qui
a beaucoup souffert
et je pense que c'est en fait c'est une
manière pour elle d'exprimer sa
souffrance encore une fois c'est pas
bien elle ne devrait pas le faire elle
le sait je le lui ai dit j'en ai
beaucoup discuté avec son mari je l'ai
écrit dans ma biographie c'est pas bien
mais elle dit qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que tu veux que ça me fasse à mon âge
qu'est-ce que tu veux qui m'arrive donc
je dis ce que je pense j'entends
parfaitement
ce côté à l'emporte-pièce ou vous parlez
de communication le problème c'est la
répétition
répétitions
donc là les nouvelles sur son état de
santé elles sont comment elles sont
bonnes elles sont bonnes ok on entend
tout et son contraire visiblement
d'après Bernard Jean-Marie
d'après lui voilà tout tout va bien
après on l'a rappelé elle va avoir 89
ans elle a des gros problèmes pour se
déplacer etc je veux dire et voilà elle
est pas elle est pas en super forme mais
visiblement pour pour Bernard il y a
aucune raison de s'inquiéter
particulièrement aujourd'hui mais ce qui
est quelque chose de très inquiétant et
pour pour les rumeurs c'est
l'insuffisance respiratoire c'est à dire
que ça c'est toujours extrêmement
dangereux surtout quand on a entre 88 89
ans c'est bien donc c'est fragile on
sait que c'est un être fragile
aujourd'hui
à quel degré il y a que Bernard
aujourd'hui on espère en tout cas que ça
va on souhaite tous parce que c'est
normal que les médecins veuillent la
garder de toute façon un médecin il va
jamais prendre le risque
d'avoir des envies surtout avec une star
mondiale pardon mais l'inquiétude est
venue parce que Johnny a eu le même
réflexe avant de nous quitter c'est ça
exactement
de la coquette et c'est comme parce
qu'il a voulu chez lui c'est là qui est
venu et c'est de la partie
c'est vrai mais la différence c'est que
Johnny tout le monde savait qu'il avait
un cancer il avait failli mourir déjà
trois ou quatre fois les années qui
précédaient on est dans une situation un
peu voilà un peu différente mais avec
des caractères un peu semblables
absolument merci des hommes déjà mais
des femmes de tête